[Music]
i don't really know what i'm buying or
uh who it's going to be for
[Music]
i never know what to get
people best put them this gift card gift
card with a basketball on it
how about this one i don't know
did you find everything you're looking
for today
yes
[Music]
no no i didn't
i just i'll be so fast so fast
[Music]
we don't want anyone to argue there's
just no need for that during the
holidays so we just buy everyone the
same thing that way
everybody's happy
come on
make it work in
make it work
[Music]
it's all about preparation i was in and
out in under an hour and i got a food
processor for my brother-in-law some
video games for my nephews and a tv for
my ex-boyfriend i even got some of next
year's holiday shopping done
this stuff is so inexpensive this time
of year
[Music]
i don't know why everyone gets birthed
up about holiday shopping i love it
[Music]
yeah
these look good
and i get cash back to spend on whatever
i want good on me
[Music]
uh
honestly i i don't know how to holiday
snuck up on me like this again but
i haven't even started yet
wish me luck
attention holiday shoppers the store
closes in 15 minutes please make your
final selections and bring them to the
registers
[Music]
did you find everything you know not
again sir
i was so fast so fast
[Music]